you
welcome everybody to my dumb friends i'm
dan st. germain are my co-host or
lovable sidekick Sean Donnelly is in New
York I'm your lovable sidekick you I
realize is that you always you said that
on the first episode I know I know it
dries exam thank you and you're such an
ego you can't even take this is a
co-host situation I don't have an ego I
say I don't have an ego yeah my love an
ego I'm very humble you guys are each
the sidekick to each other yeah exactly
the side get well blue you got a bigger
host and then we'll walk inside that
kicker or a big huh i would say bigger
uh ladies and gentlemen she's one of my
favorite comics oh he's a writer on
Conan and she's you know but on a lot of
[ __ ] Laurie Kilmartin everybody hey yeah
thank you for coming thanks for coming
into this you tricked me I don't think I
did good could you go away hey you doing
anything on sunday the twenty-eighth and
of course i think it's a spy so I dumb
it without pursuing any details like I
know I'm a wide open and you go great do
you want to do my podcast and then I
turn my phone off somehow you kept
pursuing I think I said what I think you
said I can totally Reaper we said I said
you wanna do i bought gas and you said
[ __ ] you oh yeah i'll take that as a yes
and i just got a time ok put a benefit
take it could have been way worse and
you also would have been weighing
envious ok well out of these three one
of ours a date with me a webserie shoot
or or this pod game webs and rose three
that's the worst web series of the word
i just did a web series and effort to me
that's still a casual thing and then I
got emails multiple emails about the
call sheet and I'm looking at as like
all the actors and their scene
I don't want to be in it anymore oh my
god hey kind of it makes you not want to
do it right yes yeah yeah for sure you
and your cyber professionalism makes me
want to walk away what nice fern old
said this is like can you be in my web
series is the new can you help me move
there was a lot of you really move I
guess nothing nope you drive me to the
airport yeah this is a drive-by oh yeah
you drive here the airport although I
had the most fun i did a like a pro
wrestling podcast we go ahead way more
fun with that than our podcaster well of
course you did you hate this podcast I
don't I like this podcast what do you
think I keep going because it's not like
America wants this podcast every week
it's like we both do it cuz we like it
that's true Sean where are you like are
you in a studio or your house right now
I'm on my computer at home I'd like a
desktop Angela sensory deprivation too
okay that's nice surrounded by french
fries I'm on a set of a David Blaine
special reason that's an interesting
Russia breaching it wasn't that bed you
guys do have a magic that can't be
denied I mean it's no wonder a very
black magic yeah yeah we're uh we're
Nicholas and mayo podcast my nickels in
a row as I said Nick puts comedy is
storing idiot I decided [ __ ] it up yeah
i think is that damn hot for every joke
you make but you guys wanna be called
out for any joking i just i just took it
John I just took it I'm gonna get I did
take it Jesus I had to get Laurie [ __ ]
man cuz i was talking to her about this
like you know I Sean's done Conan war
he's done conan what would she writes
for Conan mm-hmm but like I think the
first time I did it it was like one of
those things where you know people come
down and it was you Jesse pop and Josh
comers came down at the same time yes hi
yeah and it was like the most miserable
line
comedian writers like it made it worse
that you guys came you guys came down
literally you had the same posture you
held your arms back like you were in a
military funeral and looking down like
and I'm like what are they even doing
here this is a night none of you made
eye contact with me you're like hi and
I'm like sitting there nervous and when
somebody's nervous you have to be the
one to say hi but you guys just look
like like like somebody had told you to
cut Jeff Ross told you come down and
just say it was really crazy ah oh my
god that I hope we're not always i mean
we wanted to make you feel weird but we
normally want to make just say hi that
we know no oh my was in its on Dan's
head he thinks everybody has that
posture all the time I guess I do know I
don't know why woody what do you mean
they were just like they can tell you're
like I know you're right yeah this is
we're all miserable p we are and we very
uncomfortable it's also I think it's
partially like we wish we were doing the
show you know wait up make sure you're
reminded that you're all right up yeah
yeah yeah but it's always like Oh every
time a comic is doing in Conan they look
like a comic to me and I'm like yeah I'm
a writer that'd be really miserable no
matter what like if I know I know I know
I know your comic drug wants of a stable
totally i would be out yeah it's i seek
the misery for that moment yeah yeah so
if I worry if I were comic and the
writers came in to be like these guys
are [ __ ] writers yeah right on the
show yea yea yea he checked yeah exactly
no note for a while well you know it was
it that this is funny i don't know if i
have I told this on like uh podcast
Shaun White took me a while to do the
second Conan did I ever tell that I
think so well I like JP wanted me up
he's like well there's a problem in a
mic what's the problem after the first
one I thought I did pretty good sale
wipe the corner of your mouth first no I
mean he just goes it was really funny
cuz he goes he's like he's like he's
like well that some of the producers
said that during your set you've moved
too much I'm like that's crazy that's
not true and then I watched the first
set and I literally go from where I'm
supposed to stand up I went to in
background
Andy Richter I went so far the it was
like I was on a rotating restaurant Kiba
and virtually our cameras don't swivel
so we were unable to accommodate oh yeah
there's a straight chicken vacations a
microphone in the middle but it did look
ridiculous he was computed right I
looked at the imagery of all the
producers running it and have it wait a
minute he moves too much whereby they
call well there's a problem you say you
think it's a bit and it's like you yeah
so I've literally had to make another
tape where I just held the microphone
and didn't move to prove that I didn't
move all the time it was at me it was so
bad it was i guess it was such like it
was known look that I want I when I came
back but I'm like I said everybody in
the production I'm like hey I'm sorry I
moved too much and everyone laughed this
was like a cover you must have flipped
out the booth yeah I'm us where he going
where is he going yes but they were
right they were right put weight in your
shoes yeah yeah footwear anyway um but
you've been good right every time I see
you you're funny well thank you you are
you're very funny there's an easier way
to say that you're funny yeah yeah yeah
buddy he's always hoping the next time
I'll give the next time I never please
let her bomb I'm senior funny but I'm
probably to see you a lot more time and
it angers me hitting this is MIA and you
don't seem to move a lot of the snail
how do you do that you up but you also
I'd see you someone with their [ __ ]
together and not just cuz you're well
you got a kid mm-hmm is it true I don't
know maybe a little bit I guess I feel
the same way when I think about you well
I say the last time I talked to you you
were like you couldn't date a guy cuz he
had like a voice box or something wait a
voice what was it what he really are
gravely voice this guy that's snored oh
no that guy was a heavy smoker yeah and
we got along really well but I picked
you know like on the first phone call
I'm like oh you can't do this now it's
Owens 55 that means they're like 10
years from death if they're a heavy
smoker you can't you can't no i don't i
just buried somebody from like I don't
want it yeah yeah
tell him that but you know it's it
singer opener at a date I wonder why
you're single ah listen I'm sorry I was
late I just buried my father forgetting
think you're doing right now from the
same thing but if someone's like 30
maybe they could quit but if someone's
like 55 it's quick it's like a lifelong
habit that's yeah it's over yeah um has
dating now I'm not dating you done no I
I don't know what to do I don't know how
to my mother moved in with me like two
weeks yea though so I'm sort of just
Regis that is like the move equivalent
of sweatpants for wife really it's also
worse with a guy over yeah who's what's
the joke no it's interesting about that
though your mom moved in with you isn't
as bad as you moving in with your mom
it's true yeah yeah yes I shows a lot of
stability yeah how is that going by the
way um well she's a good grandma so it's
good for my kid to have somebody else in
the right but you know it's um I I did
have a talk with her about I need my
space on the weekends which I don't want
to talk to her at all like I just need
to decompress yeah I need my space and
by that I mean don't talk to me for 40
ago basically yes it's almost exactly it
and so she was in her bedroom almost all
day yesterday and it was you know she
has a TV in there and she just has been
watching so I'm like oh this is perfect
I think she like she came out and her
little slippery wolf your son and your
mom and iPad at dinner no what no one
look mommy in the eye well it was she
binge watching The Good Wife or
something she was doing Mozart in the
jungle well she's a hello yeah I mean
yes lady I haven't even watched that I
want to see the other one Golden Gloves
in it yeah what a whole bunch it's
really good yeah so you just keep her in
the room you just lock her up yeah it is
a version of the room the Oscar nominees
not allowed to leave go to Lori sorry
she's like can I get dinner today
shut up mom sorry its got like a tube
shoots food in that would be ideal she's
not a long grown up or no no its you
know classic mother-daughter [ __ ] but I
have a have a garage that I totally
tricked-out so that's where I go and
it's down like yep don't pardon me I
said pimp my garage sorry yeah yeah yeah
yeah how did what's your boys version of
tricking it out it's it's all it's all
drywalled like and I've got a little
couch in there tribal fault if there's
all well you know like white drywall it
looks like a regular room right right
yeah and he doesn't know what walls are
hey lives on the street I mean nobody
thinks it's where I wall is an ice wall
worry nobody thinking of like Wells cuz
you're just cuz your walls are wet as
opposed to just studs in a garage and
writers and insulin we're having a
garage there's a stud in the girls like
go drive walnut barna so if you have
cars in there now know it I have a car
in there I put some flooring in there
and and then French doors what do you do
out there you just like smoke pot or
what well my version of smoking pot is
doing my artists way pages what are your
artists what's the artist what yeah you
ever heard of the artist way yeah where
they do they tell you how to draw
something no you oh wait no well I don't
know what this is all right don't give
me that look your guesses are so far off
it's endearing what is it or not it's
it's this book on how to access your
creativity and they do I don't think ed
but the the top thing that pretty much
everyone remembers about it is you write
three pages a day stream of
consciousness yeah and so when I do it
in my in our little house one of the two
of these the nine-year-old of the
seventy eight-year-old is just clawing
at me asking for things so yeah I go
into the garage and then I'm by myself
that's perfect it's nice for me yeah
it's nice ish yeah it's nice dish yeah
yeah you got we should have the space to
do that yeah you were you're all in an
apartment in New York you would be
screwed oh my god it's so hard to and I
mean it's so hard when you're like
cuz I'm trying to write something else
when you're on a show it's so hard yeah
oh it's my god that's impossible yeah
yeah you don't your I do think your
brain can get tired like at the end of
the day if I you know if it's like a
show day over in like 40 jokes and I'm
like I have nothing left and if I if I
just think of one new tag later that
night on stage it's a mean one yeah yeah
what's the most garbage joke you've ever
like push to go my god I mean there's
there been one where you're just like
what is this isn't even a joke one that
like stuck out in your brain I don't
ever they don't stick out but i I've
read a lot of bad jokes every day yeah
but I don't realize it until later when
I reread them like I like you know um
you just sort of write in a frenzy and
try to clean up the grammar and stuff
like that and because you never know
what he's gonna pick you know after
after at a certain point you're like you
know you eliminate some things you know
he hates but yeah after that you're like
well maybe that'll that'll work and then
later in the day I'd go back and see if
I can repurpose anything for myself and
I feel like oh my god I showed this to
konoha Brian this is so embarrassing I
wanna die he's probably used to those
he's like a writer first yeah yeah I
mean yeah and we all before you know all
of us kind of you know lob turds every
once in a while yeah you gotta turn [ __ ]
a little bit yeah yeah yeah you can't
that's actually my nickname and the
writers are interred lob turn lobber
sounds like the worst Batman villain
lobber that's pretty good your shows
really funny though the pilot was great
watched another one it's very funny yeah
I think I got a couple jokes in this
week that's cool who are the guests this
week let's Bridget Everett and Jim
Jefferies okay we got some good ones
yeah yeah I saw the one with Doug Benson
and Ron Funches oh yeah yeah they have
those guys are great yeah it's uh it's
definitely weird to be on a show you
know like I have noticed this like for
show about sex and relationships I've
never been in a writer's or any room
with less sexual tension haha and my
entire life yeah it's insane yeah it's
so so graphic and blatant that nobody's
aroused nobody he
tried I sort of got like there's like
there is not one iota of attraction
between any writers yeah um besides this
writer's assistant Joe who's kind of
dreamy but yes that well it's literally
like this Joe know you have a crush on
him everybody has a crush on Joe okay
you know what that's because of the
subject matter or just because it just
worked out that way what he's got like a
i think it's i think yeah I think it's a
lot of it's the subject matter is you're
riding with someone you see the work
what cuz all of its our own personal
stories yeah so when you like when when
a girl hears about how I got a hand job
outside jersey mike's like they're not
just like they're not like oh man I
wonder what he's like in the bed I know
yeah yeah I know and I am definitely not
a fan so yeah I mean I don't think that
makes sense then if you phoned us if
you're writing about sex all day you're
like look at somebody at that yeah well
it's different than when you go outside
of the writers room then all of a sudden
you're like it's like animated birds
come in your over oh my god I'm gonna be
attractive yeah then and then you [ __ ]
one of the animated birds yeah exactly I
didn't have you gone on any of the
remotes do you do any of that yeah I did
the porn one you know the one where it
was like we did in your porn know it
where um we fed we felt oh yeah yeah I
just need that one guy on that one oh
that's great yeah and I was feeding some
wines uh and then uh yeah i was on i'm
gonna do i'm on a couple new ones come
down and i'm on the one this I was on
the one this week cool how are the
ratings ah the social media stuffs
really good that's cool you know I mean
ratings are so crazy it's so weird now
our social media to get the pipe the
podcast numbers are good and you know
hopefully that it's not [ __ ] weird
like fri i remember someone saying that
a lot of people don't even know Key &
Peele was on comedy central because they
just saw did you too but it was yeah
yeah yeah man I think Schumer was the
same way even she even Schumer Wow so a
comedy central's just sort of oh there
was like there was something about how
people they pulled a bunch of people
that were under the age of 19 yeah
and they knew more of them new with this
so ever this youtuber this vine guy was
more than Tom who Tom Hanks was wow wow
we're gonna be done yeah PewDiePie
whatever PewDiePie oh yeah he was just
on Conan yeah who is that he's a Swedish
guy that at I down south park was he the
south part 1 on Sam no I see oh goody do
a show about him yeah yeah I think he
was out at the end of it and he was he
does these these videos where he sort of
a place i think is it he plays video
games and he just talks over it ya my
kid watches them all that not him
necessarily about those kind of videos
all the time it's vicious it's such a
strange way to become a superstar yeah
you know Oh Jared freed Oh opened up for
one of these guys and my god I've or
whatever or whatever it was at we're
like lemony live up in palisades oh my
god it sounds like the most casual
gommino ebrochure oh okay yeah but but
Jared overcome this guy Jared did 15
minutes on zone they come out they do a
personal appearance they do they do 20
minutes oh my god and then they go nuts
and then as a joke it was all over cited
audience there's like packed with 14
year old girls and before Jared brings
him out he goes I'm sorry this got one
of the guys got the guys name he goes he
couldn't make it hahahahaha make it said
eggs was in the daytime and all the dads
that with the girls they started kind of
laughing as they knew he was kidding but
then he said one little girl looks right
in his face and goes get off this yeah
but wouldn't be him what if they turn to
comedy around and turn it into where you
could do 20 minutes to headline oh that
would be a man I would be amazed you
imagine let's you would write so much
new stuff my god yes uh who is so great
that would be great that's so when you
go on the road and somebody's like yeah
you can do an hour you're like 40 bucks
40-45 min straight birdies the Magic Man
yeah artis the one you're like thanks
yeah yeah yeah yeah no I like when I do
road stuff but you know like I'll go
like do laughs and two signers a place
where you it's kind of dirty being kind
of just make sure you can do 45 minutes
still yeah yeah
it's so I don't know I'm like uh I'm
doing these jokes again I'm reminded by
how much I'm trying to get like at least
I Mike almost at the point where I have
new material almost an hour from my half
hour three years ago that's amazing
almost mask like 40 minutes but a lot of
that was on my album and I did some of
it on Conan but hopefully I have enough
they're like I guess you owe ya doin
those rogue eggs is that if you're
writing for the show you can kind of use
those rogue gigs to write new stuff
while you're there right a little bit
yeah i mean its shopping kill yeah yeah
yeah that's ill but you can always go
back to those to the a but you can throw
new new stuff in between sure I do but
I'll like I'll do that in LA so like I
was just telling I when I was in New
York I did like 16 spots in a weekend or
in four days or something but by by the
end of it I was you know i wish i had
done like 15 3 minutes that's cuz i yeah
you do that stuff you want to work on
and then you're like all right yeah I
here's here's a few you know i'll just
do the stuff yeah we're a few ringers
yeah yeah an AMS New York every day to
you ah yes and when you go back it's
like this place is this place is perfect
it really is when you're visiting it's
way better than living there that's true
I've done a mama question that's a
shitty quality of living I remember
getting really burnt out but when you
when you come back here I mean people
here are such garbage guy really are
there's some garbage people Eddie what
do you mean like comics or bones are
just any man Eve none inc anyone in
comedy yeah talking about just the city
in general yeah there's so many people
here but you live in a place without
walls so your point of view it's a
little skewed i have a couple walls
emotional what's that what's what do you
think is the dumbest move you've ever
put on like on stage where you're like
I'm gonna try this out oh my god Mike
closer my road closer yea years was me
pretending to be a penis and not trying
to talk the girl out of using a condom
and I don't oh I did a yeah it was but
it was it was all so embarrassed
well I guess I person as I as I I felt
like I matured as a comic I was like oh
my god like it worked and it was clever
ish it was such a dick joke that I I
feel like stuttering when I think about
it I'm like oh my god yeah yeah Jay
oakerson was on our bodies and he said
his closer when he first started was he
would just get naked on stage wife Annie
was just like just so pathetic it's
interesting though that guy is so
comfortable on stage so funny that I
wonder if that was part of him getting
there getting comfortable shut up not
intentionally but maybe getting
comfortable with his body and shutting
up a baby that's like I went sat or
something and just going I [ __ ] own
this stage and this is my body cuz he's
almost this he is the stage in a way but
you don't feel like he's visiting and
there's a most complimentary fat joke
ever it's he's not even fat anymore hey
so I swine ya know nobody's paying semen
imagine biting back no I mean well [ __ ]
I can't wait to seize me special fine
whatever and one of the funniest guy but
as far as weight i meanyes he's better
than he was but you know I don't think
Jay is Jay's not gonna call himself a
[ __ ] hunk you know it said phones are
on either um I I see now magic is you
have a kid you have like a full-time job
that like you have to be more selective
with who I went totally yeah yeah how
many tests do they have to pass haven't
gotten past a date in a long time it's
not like when you're like when you're
not married or nice white right is that
the test right if you're not if your mom
has to be at least six foot three my
rabbit my son's requests not mine yeah
if you don't have a kid but I'm just
saying you know the kid you can have a
lot more like try this guy a totally
irresponsible I lived with people I live
with guys cuz I'm like what could what
give it a shot it's out you did that
what is what the other worse what do you
think is the most ridiculous like moving
situation you've been where you're like
I'll just try this out okay it's true
yes Padre but it was a sister it works
out on the couch by the way he was it
you had no filter you're like
his day does he have headphones on a
show he doesn't he's playing Minecraft I
wouldn't know if he was on fire right
now you wouldn't realize yeah so crap
being a mom how about this [ __ ] her son
is literally right next to us as we do
this podcasters like yeah dem I'd is dad
would never bet it okay so i'm working
in san antonio yeah oh and whatever
center yeah and the feature is yeah a
local guy yeah and we hit it off for the
weekend and at the end of the weekend
this is thanksgiving week it's a and I
go why don't you move to New York you
could live with me and this is dad yeah
and it has a feature I didn't know that
oh not expect that story so um so cuz I
was like yeah and then I and it you know
yeah he did about a month later and um
you know as I realized I'm starting the
store I realize there's a lot of details
like give right now what I would say
that's not that was my thing up hey
what's the worst that could go how long
before went sour um you know I would say
days but because he had moved from Texas
to New York you know it was like a huge
move you're like oh we really gonna try
I'm like if a kid together that's the
ultimate give it a try it is I really
like the kid work down yeah so yeah
after like a couple days you're like
this is yeah was there one thing you can
tell us that was like I know that this
is this is not going anywhere I I I
think the person he's Sean left by the
way I listen when I moved to New York I
was like this place is amazing like it
like it activated every cell in my body
right and so I assume everyone else
would feel that way especially a comic
and that feeling wasn't wasn't shared
and then when someone moves to New York
and they don't like New York yeah
they're going to be unhappy uh yeah yeah
yeah oh you're back what were you doing
in there how did you gotta go the chart
there for second hear what you said did
you get like a raisinet stuck in your
belly button I don't know what my kid
just said I heard you pardon okay what
is that you want to go do you want to go
sit outside okay oh my god you an
updated her son did hear everything that
he was talking about I just said I heard
the fire line I want to hear all the bad
stuff you're talking oh my god can we
skype in a child there is this you know
how you're supposed to talk about dumb
things you've done in your past that
just has this alive dumb things that
you've actually captured in a podcast
same though this might be me want to do
the show is you wanna come on these
welcome to come on suggest can talk
about his dumb mom we could ask we can
ask what's the dumbest thing as mom's
everyday poet you probably don't want to
do that hey I'll keep them on yeah
you're gonna keep him off that was that
was great yeah he doing the jug by
throwing him into the pool haha he's
heard that he's heard that one he's fine
with that yeah he knows all you knows
all I have huh there's a smart kid right
here you mean Dan um yeah I'm I guess
I'm like I'm not a man but i'm not i'm
not a boy but I'm not yet a man that
isn't very accurate it was that a
Britney yes I'm not a girl yet a woman
that's right that's right yeah I'm not
like an adult yet no Dan just talks in
country music lyrics today's Randy
Travis day is that that's another one he
said they're gonna finish that are you
guys allowed to talk to the guests
adored you just stay upstairs and we
usually don't talk to the guests we're
usually working the whole time but they
do have been a nightmare down there I
wouldn't be able to say but that's a yes
yes but
I was able to meet Carol Burnett I did
request oh oh that's all wow that was
awesome here's my request I and I met
Carol Burnett Chrissie Hynde and
Chrissie Hynde send the pretenders okay
and uh I was thinking about that who's
that other hind Jessica hind like porn
star from like the 90s oh yeah we'd love
to definitely she would be a
high-quality definitely asked calling he
loves putting porno stars on that you
and Elizabeth Warren oh that's cool you
should be good that's very nice how's
Elizabeth Warren the coolest does she
get drunk before her yes she's
completely any good no she's so she's so
nice and down-to-earth and not pull not
politician II you know yeah and her
granddaughter was there and yeah it
seems really cool we got in a political
discussion before this he did podcast
it's really were so bad at it yeah it is
like if fraud that bad crossfire was
just took place and like a Down Syndrome
Foundation so you're not is informed as
one would think hahaha so you're telling
you dad yeah people think I'm a Nobel
laureate when they first meet me uh
worried and starts talking about
politics than you think he's are the
Unabomber like oh somebody to get a
letter you do have early Kaczynski i had
a haircut yesterday this is like which
hair did they cut Floyd's barber shop in
Venice what is this may vary no no
there's a chain it's a chain no annoying
like how we don't Helene they didn't
good job really they hit defensive about
a barber I i think they deliberately
pick the name floyd because it's sort of
like on hip it's kind of whistling all
to me Barry oh that's right yeah that's
probably wrong I don't think there's an
actual are you 80 years old huh your
references are like so like you would be
so happy in like Branson Missouri
I'm real employed the barber I'm
bringing up right now no one cares you
could write if you could we're
guaranteed a massive amount of income
yeah II like six shows a day and had to
be squeaky clean for a branson odd I
couldn't do it first off you someone
could write you do six shows a day you
saw it I think a knockoff did that many
some a huge amount but they're really
short shows does it save it's just like
three shows a night 30 minutes max yeah
and you just you say the word you're
given and you have a brand Oh money am I
getting paid it's this is branson money
man i'm presently what will allow you to
judging in mizuki seventy thousand
dollars a year hundreds say half a
million a year would you do it a million
I couldn't I wouldn't want to live in
Missouri you couldn't leave because you
it's like six or seven days a week it's
like Vegas but it's not even in Vegas
yeah I mean I wasn't case to be clean
anymore that's what it's like yeah yeah
no I don't think I could do it yeah
although I'd probably be a fox out there
oh that would be I go I'm like a branson
missouri Santa Paul bet you if you
change your name to Paul Bunyan and then
you did like a lumberjack like these are
in minutes lumberjack and Branson no
changing it up onions and then your
whole bit is about your feet like a plan
to me I would work Paul Bunyan oh and
your opening act Sarah cankles oh but
yeah my Blue Ox is just the name of my
orthopedic shoes my blue get up my blue
boxes up I think we've hit the Paul
Bunyan trained enough Oh think we every
possible reference yes he's gonna watch
yeah yeah exactly Blue Ox we got it not
knocked it out of the park on there why
not didn't wasn't what's his name was
there for a long time Bob Nelson no
really that guy was such a dick to me
who's Bob Nelson Nelson no he's a hit
p m / he was big in like the 80s yeah he
was like on his way to being famous and
then something happen it was part of a
comedy trio with Eddie Murphy right
really Oh was he really something he was
he who had some very thin tie like Eddie
on the way up bumped into him or
something but they were linked for a
little while oh yeah he's super funny
back in the day but now I'm Facebook
friends with him now he's just like a
super right wing nutjob yeah he is he
was a dick to you yeah I worked with him
I was featuring at the end he was head
laying at the at the funny the comedy
zone in Charlotte yeah and I think you
know about my closer I just told you
about your amazing day by the way
squeaky clean bed don't swear in it at
all really yes but it is a penis that
Jeff you're saying it's like I'm gonna
book you for something besides another
another really inconvenient he wouldn't
he never talked to me or look me in the
eye and he would say he would apologize
for my act I'm home today's audience cuz
he's super slow motion and I'm not even
that filthy especially back then I
wasn't I think I might have had wine
abortion joke though now but I think
about it that he probably if but that
crowd liked it and they've crowd was
like what but he started every show like
that and then it's on the sunday show he
or the lash m8 was saturday night cuz i
think it was sunday he apologized
through his friend he said it was he
said I I'm to eat Bob said to tell you
he's sorry about the way he acted this
week oh wow yeah horrible guy horrible
guy I hope he ends up in Branson
Missouri that's nothing right oh my god
it came true my dream came true not what
what have you say her i said that's he's
he's no longer in branson he is room
back in New York amis mana thang long
island yet quorum me from Long Island
yeah Long Island what a [ __ ] all sorry
Sean it's [ __ ] up but what are gonna do
but he but that's in her confident he's
doing that the whole weekend and then
apologizing it by proxy at in the
weekend yeah yeah yeah that means that
he
there's like there's an inner battle
that's going on there yeah with the
devil and his soul the devil and the
smaller devil devil I'm not as bad devil
yeah yeah I mean you meet these guys
when you're I mean especially when
you're featuring that you're just like I
only had a couple rounds like you know
what this guy sucks yeah and you're like
this isn't how I want to get old in this
business no its depository tale yeah
yeah a lot of cautionary tales I will
say when you do like have a staff job
stand up becomes a lot more fun cuz
you're like all right I'm remaking my
money yeah you know it was like I'm
simply play many for sure come secondary
almost for a while yeah it's awesome p
it's good being on a good show where you
can be yeah you can check it out rather
cuz I've been on oh we were on some
shows run Mike what are you worried for
him like I don't worry about do you mean
when you play rest Jeff on the electric
company I was brilliant in that how does
an act that was my first credit was I
was wrecked upon a children's show
really were you were you I was 20 oh I
thought you were a kid no no I was 26
and I was like really sweaty and the
kids were really mean to me and now
you're 27 now I 31 i'm 20 i was 25 do
you for real that you Holly that I was
25 I think wow I didn't know the
electric company was still taping new
episode it's not anymore I really ran
that thing on the ground my one guest
starring in am as part of the reboot
well they gave me you know I'm such a
[ __ ] as far as learning lines they gave
me the script like three days beforehand
and it was all like math formulas so I
was all like Rory is like just yawning
throughout this whole podcast oh my god
talking about my shitty acting career
always tired I always yawn I always I
always yawn I was yawning last night at
night I on during the day it's just all
so sitting what you do yeah yeah I have
a standing desk at work so I don't sit
really this long you don't yes I do you
have a standing date with a treadmill
underneath it no you don't next time we
do the show come to my office I'll show
you you have us you have a treadmill yep
an ikea a bar table which is like 45
inches tall and I and then underneath
that I put it to that must be the
craziest thing to watch if you're anyone
else in that office I guess it's your
own you have your own office yeah yeah
luckily no one seeing you like getting
on a treadmill I wits let you walk so
slow that it's you know it's something
la are you right at the hey don't I read
in the morning when I'm reading for
premises that's when I do it and then
when I'm writing you can actually it's
harder when you cept you stand or
dressed and yeah I'll kind of bury it up
and I also sit too i have a high chair
where I sit on but I I feel like Josh
comers just lays down while he writes
does the opposite he just stood says his
jokes to his therapist I weighed down a
lot time he's gone now he moved verzi
and now New York yeah he I guess I saw
job is he available tonight show he's on
Fallon out oh he is yeah oh wow I wanted
to go out of LA yeah his cuz he has a
baby and his family on the on the East
Coast he wanted his baby to be near
family you know oh wow and his wife is
Australian so she doesn't have family
here or there so I guess she just does
what he want his post on Facebook well I
think yeah I think it was still tough to
move because she had friends here stuff
but yeah right you want I guess we have
it when you have the kid is a baby you
want them to be their grandparents so
who's so it's just you and who else is
on monologue it's me brian Kylie um Rob
Kutner and we just hired Leah krinsky
you know leo she's a comic and she was
jeez did you stand up and she was on
Dennis Miller and Bill Maher so she's
really nice yeah yeah oh well well we
both ran out of steam on that one hahaha
that's comfortable this podcasters we're
just having a conversation what have you
now have you got on uh what's it called
the debt like that oh my god I don't
know why I'm having a hard time saying
this but uh wow I have been talking for
a while but have you like have you got
on one of these like like tinder dates
and like like 10 minutes and you're like
this is
I have you had one where you're like wow
this is not a not a tinder date it was a
I'm not an tinder I feel like I'm too
old to be on tinder I think I don't know
about that I don't know so wilford
brimley on there the other day oh I'm
hot for that guy I gotta I gotta get on
yahoo every medical swiped our my dance
comes with diabetes loved one happy to
see them diabetes I don't know I'm a
cord cutter guys I haven't seen
commercial years and uh there was a guy
I had a coffee with and I sat down and I
was like oh I don't feel safe with this
guy why what was he he was really tall
the time we got coffee yeah I could
escape from you that's actually what's
on my tinder profile don't worry ladies
I'm easy to escape from yes she is way
more stamina that's right I could walk
away from you oh you guys he was so tall
this dude was really tall enough no I
don't feel safe I gotta go and that was
it he was just tall and yeah yeah there
was nothing like he wasn't talking about
taxidermy on almost almost seven feet
tall so that it was really too tall for
me yeah did you have like a deep voice
that like those Mongoloids have one
really tough hey Gloria War II yeah it
mongoid do you think like really tall
guy should like the NBA they always hook
up with like little five-foot like it's
almost like they know some of them
shacks wife was am was a monster right I
don't remember she ate eucalyptus off
trees um that's very bare light yeah
very bare like no I wish I think some of
them are taller but aunt accusers those
guys just [ __ ] everything yeah you know
they're just yeah so in this guy shut up
you just got a bad vibe from your like
and so you kind of have to have that as
a woman I think going out you had a
sixth sense like yes good yeah I'm here
yeah yeah yeah I didn't want to miss a
we made another date which I agree to
just so to get out of this
the night eXID enemas I don't think so
uh yeah I've had um I've had some rough
ones I mean oh I said it I've actually
the past two weeks I've hooked up with
oh you know the couple girls but either
both of them it was like I've never had
the like I can tell they're fine with
not seeing me again okay I've never
happy like look why isn't this guy
calling me they're like it was those
fine you know there's ever been like oh
man this guy yeah nuts about this guy
like I don't think there's ever there's
not one girl on planet earth right now I
was like man that was the one that got
away you're like oatmeal and that you're
satisfying but there's no need to have
really on a good day hopefully very off
gran oatmeal I've definitely gotten
worse at UH at sex for sure now I'll
just go now looks like i'll go down on a
girl just so i don't have to do the
cardio I'm normal so I don't know what I
just what I don't think he even knows
what's happening just said he knew yes
speaking you know what I'm not gonna
take any chickens I didn't say I was
gonna light him on fire or whatever the
hell Laurie just said Casey Anthony over
here the KCNA a comedy haha that's great
it's a great day you should but you
should have t-shirts made up the Casey
Anthony of comedy she is actually open
to photography I that's what I heard yes
she's the new Ansel Adams oh my god
beautiful woman yeah I actually am
attracted to her and a man this is my
amanda knox imagine no didn't do it i
don't think she had a person who killed
that girl um they stay there was a guy
that they think yeah you know yeah black
guy no I'm just too good I don't know
but I do think actually now he's black
so now just one area oh my god I support
black I say black when it's actually a
black dude I don't know what it is I
think he's far in though who this just
sounds worse I'll tell you know right
aren't they wasn't didn't the song yeah
Italy yeah yeah but you know anyway
there's no way I could Casey definitely
murdered her daughter yeah but they're
both kind of hot yeah there's kind of
murdery retractor to it
murderer i'm addicted to um you know I
don't know if he's guilty but the guy
well mark what an arm on that guy no
actually the right back yeah that's not
very convincing he's running back but
very but that he murdered with that arm
that's what i was talking about i was
talking about his football chatter I'm
like what is he gonna flash a throat
across not an arm on that guy um no I'm
gonna say Peterson right you see
Peterson no no no he looks like he looks
like a flick though doesn't he been a
slacker operators Dean Cain I thought it
looks like Dean cake okay oh yeah I'm
okay inflate a minute okay this is a
long time ago yeah this guy was he at
now than thinking about it he was played
by Mark Harmon in a TV movie and that
might be who I have a crush on but it's
the sky was an army doctor who was
accused of killing his entire family and
I always swore he was innocent I think
he just saw summer school the movie you
focus you know who was at my show last
night that guy who first dated Jennifer
Aniston yeah great hate something say on
ax men Tate Donovan hey Donovan Wow
flavors him once nice guy all right I
said hey I really i think i can really
become friends of the Watusi with
celebrities out of his kato kaelin thing
yeah I have a variac a tie for character
actors dude I saw a Kathryn Erbe a you
look at that Kevin ER Bay is no no she
was uh she's in law and order criminal
intent she was like the daughter and
what about Bob and what about Bob a
daughter oh yeah remember her yeah yeah
jello at JFK yeah yeah talking to harm
for a couple minutes a good story really
good stir oh wait till you hear is tom
noonan story it's just as great wait
would you guys talk of it just goes hey
al Newman and Tom goes high took him
like seven minutes to tell ago oh you're
ones for Liam Neeson's haha oh man that
guy type there's a picture of him naked
um running while naked I guess it wasn't
what is it does that he'll he writes to
you get on a treadmill and run
good he was he was in a film where he
had to run very quickly to a pool and
yeah naked and I feel good yeah it looks
amazing it was a while like he's doing
well dabbler doing very well down there
he's a tall guy doesn't matter yeah good
itself to course it does as urban a time
ago I don't know this isn't this is not
happening no it's it it's always if it's
happening it's good you know no but I
mean has there ever been like a good
that that guy on the couch just you know
exit of my womb not many years ago so
maybe I'm blown way out of proportion
now you know what I'm saying that I to
judge anyone yeah now you need like a
baby tremor I really hope those
headphones are working well I think
we've talked in enough oh that I think
hey are your headphones on okay music is
immediately able to hear you or goes
your headphones out immediately he goes
yes wait they don't seem like they're
I'm I don't see them let me see your
ears at it is you're so full of snot
alright okay alright quite but if he's a
really good kid is he get cigarettes
after this to get the vibe cigarettes
and lotto tickets you never gonna watch
to get her a kid talk on I think he
should end up oh this is like if you
ever murders you this podcast is gonna
be evidence he's gonna get a really
short term um Laurie you're gonna it's
not next week or coming up with a week
after the podcast you everything though
oh so what we can decide what it's uh
geez its uh girl me will get up well
it's filled with some stuff well I woke
this stuff up so uh those are nice shoes
mine yeah
thanks I actually have they march 11
much 11 didn't really care about the
shoes why can't any other words they had
a conversation with Kathryn lb yeah Irby
or whatever her back they are the lights
off now Shawn in there uh-oh what's
going on over there you see me yeah I
care a little bit yeah yeah so there's
sometimes where you haven't been
laughing during funny parts and I've
actually secretly resented you for that
ok can I can i plug a good podcast I'm
doing with Jackie Kashian yeah ok it's
it's called the Jackie and Laurie show
jaka is a great great comedian and yeah
we awesome we don't have any guests
because I don't want to be I don't want
to pull a dan Jermaine on somebody my
instrument actually but thank you for
knowing me for years and not no no I use
your middle name all but it's not a
middle name my middle name is pencil
it's not sooner pencil yeah listen here
so many problems and it's it's on iTunes
is under distinct you got a nervous one
i canna pop there pop I'm on you know
the show I write for and then I have
another podcast their eye on comedy
central's think it's on to tia tuesdays
at ten-thirty we're after tosh it's
really on the road again why should I on
comedy central's app that i watch on
Apple TVs yeah that's good it's really
Conan is always good yeah you guys I
think it's been I think it's been way
better to the past couple years yeah it
feels like it yeah like I I think he's a
gun I don't give a [ __ ] I'm like yeah
veteran cop with nothing to lose yeah
exactly you know yeah yeah yeah I like
it a lot thank you so much worries
thanks time thanks Sean I would consider
you a comedy treasure hahaha calling
back something that I don't think he
recorded right Aaron Aaron what would
what know it we didn't record that I
don't damn it Aeryn get your [ __ ]
together what do you have to advertise
just awesome dan you can buy my album
how about that have a Sean over here in
New York City what's the what's manual
labor face manual labor hmm that's funny
that's not
that's my office what it O'Connor mrs.
O'Connor said that shitty you left the
stage and O'Connor what up shutting us
more like manual labor act O'Connor
stupid he got you Sean he got ya yeah
sassy [ __ ] yeah yeah a little he's a
mean girl that guy uh thank you so much
thank goodness CUA Chris I
thank you for listening to the my dumb
friends podcast to keep track of where
our hosts will be performing live go to
dan st. germain net and check out his
show calendar his upcoming dates in and
around Los Angeles and across the
country Wisconsin Washington Canada
Texas and so on so check it out Sean
Donnelly has a website Sean Donnelly
comedy com check out his shows link he's
going to be performing in around new
york city and across the country from
westport to the moontower comedy
festival in austin and beyond this
weekend your podcast producer myself
thomas attila lewis well i'm helping run
the high mud comedy festival in north
adams massachusetts friday and saturday
march 11th and 12th we've got great
lineup of comedians for two days of
comedy we've got Sean Patton headlining
we've got Dave hill doing shows and
we've got TIG Notaro headlining you get
a festival pass go to mass moca org and
there's also free shows every night in
North Adams at various venues go to mass
moca org and check out the high mud
Comedy Festival thanks for listening
we'll be back next week
for other cool comedy podcasts go to all
things comedy com yes we're a part of
the all things comedy network we're one
of many great comedy podcasts that's all
things comedy com our opening and
closing song is called Mary the boxer by
Phil Pickens you can find out more about
Phil at Phil Pickens com
nah
you don't
me
yes you can Oh
you